Oh last figure of worship here please
thank you yeah thank you for the
invitation
yeah according to schedule I have until
4:00 right so yeah this talk is called
fully understanding the hashing trick
this is don't walk with Kasper flexin
and cuspid in larson from office
University I'm going to start with some
motivation real-world motivation so
classification and accommodation system
so take for example Netflix so assuming
that everybody here is some at some
point of time watch the Netflix movie
suppose you watch and epics movie not
Netflix immediately recommends other
movies for you which it considers
similar so how do we decide which movies
are similar so yeah and so as humans
it's very easy if we were to recommend a
movie to a friend we consider what the
movie has what the movie doesn't have
and all kinds of attributes but yeah
these are called categorical variables a
computer cannot handle these so how do
we transfer this to something a computer
can an algorithm can handle so we take
all these characteristics and match them
to 0 1 vector two bit vectors which are
called feature vectors ok let's for the
rest of the talk do you know the
featured dimension by n
so what happens then so we have the
entire collection of movies that the
Netflix silver hair this is called the
corpus so first of all no that's storing
the entire corpus if you have a movies
it takes Omega of nm memory and suppose
now Netflix purchases the rights for a
new movie then we need to find the K
closest movies to it that's the K
nearest neighbors problem and comparing
two vectors let's say the l2 distance it
takes linear time okay so how can we
make this easier so one trick is to
reduce the dimension what is what I mean
by dimensionality reduction so given
some epsilon and Delta where epsilon is
the approximation approximation ratio
and Delta is the error probability we
want a function okay we a random
function from RN 12m such that for every
x and y the l2 distance is approximately
preserved
okay for this talk you think about n is
very large and M is very small and we
want this current T okay so the
probability of the image T of the
distance between the images to be
between 1 mark plus or minus epsilon the
original distance is larger than 1 minus
Delta for this talk we will talk about
linear projections yeah why is that so
aside from the fact that linear is cool
it works well under streaming and it is
very efficient in practice okay so yeah
so since it's linear we can put X&Y into
F like this since this is a linear
equation and again since this is a
linear equation we can concentrate on
just maintaining the l2 norm of one
vector okay so far everything is clear
so this is a very well-known problem and
it has a very well-known solution the
jobs we did Johnson minister's lemma so
this can be achieved with M being
although vlog 1 over delta over epsilon
squirrel
this is known to be optimal and in most
known proofs the matrix is very very
sparse okay usually it's a matrix of
independent Gaussian so I'm applying the
embedding takes order of M and
operations we want to do this a bit
faster than that so one approach to do
that is to try and find sparse matrices
that do the say that guarantee the same
guarantees so sparse JL by Cain and
Nelson they showed that this is possible
to do with the same I am the same
dimension log 1 over Delta over epsilon
square but every column has at most log
1 over Delta over epsilon zeros this
means that we can embed much much faster
ok so negative salon is small as epsilon
R M and this is almost tight ok so you
get an S ensure that s has to be at
least log 1 over Delta over Epsilon and
there's another log 1 over epsilon
factor over them ok so do we have hope
to do anything better so apparently we
do so just to be clear so far everything
is clear it's clear what I'm talking
about
ok so apparently in practice
Weinberger adalat 2009 they introduced
feature hashing which is also known as
the hashing trick so the idea is this
you take a vector X and you shuffle it
with random signs what does it mean so
let's assume M is 3 just to contain it
in a single slide so we take each code
in a each entry of X we assign it with a
random sign and put it in a random back
bucket ok we continue doing that I guess
the idea is clear by now ok and
eventually we maintain the sketch this
is the sketch and surprisingly enough
the norms are the same but the current
we want a guarantee with high
probability and of course
so formally what does it mean we choose
a random hash function from n to M and
we choose random signs these are all
independent and for every X in RN you
can see why pasta responded to a second
slide the eyes coordinate the entry of f
of X is just the sine sum of all those
entries of X that are mapped to the ice
bucket
okay this clear if not think about the
image from the previous slide this
operation is of course linear and
moreover it is as fast as possible so
every entry of X is only considered once
but previously we just said that this
cannot guarantee what we want for all
vectors so why does it work in practice
[Music]
so just a warm up so let's say let's
take a unit vector X and let's take the
random variable capital X to be the
square norm of the sketch minus the
square norm of the original vector this
is one just a sanity check to see that
you're following okay so the expected
value of x is 0 and the variance is at
most 2 over m what does this mean that
if I want the probability of maintaining
up to 1 plus minus epsilon the norm of X
how large do I need em to be that's
chebyshev inequality we need it to be at
least 2 over epsilon squared Delta
okay if you think about epsilon and
Delta is very very small especially
Delta okay the epsilon squared in
denominator
apparently we cannot do anything with it
but if you think of Delta is very very
small then this is not too good okay
this means that I can in fact preserve
norms of every vector but I need em to
be very very loud okay so if I increase
M by much I can somehow still get
guarantees okay they I mean the lower
bounds we discussed earlier for the
optimal
dimension for m being loved one over
Delta over epsilon squared so if I
increase did I mention I can do much
better but this is too much a cost
and this is more or less the best we can
do if we want to guarantee something for
all vectors because if you think about
this vector I know it's not a unit
vector but putting one of us quote two
was less nice so this vector if you if
we hash it to M buckets what is the
probability that we maintain the norm so
it's exactly the probability that there
is no collision and this probability is
1 over m so if we want no collisions
with probability at most at least 1 over
the 1 minus Delta we need m to be at
least 1 over Delta so we cannot escape
that ok we clear so far
so again why does it work well in
practice
so one parameter which you should pay
special attention to is this the ratio
between the Infinity norm of X and the
l2 norm of X ok so this vector has a
value of 1 over square root 2 for this
parameter ok the Infinity norm is just
the largest coordinate of X so what
happens if X is more balanced what
happens if the mass of X is not
concentrated in very few coordinates so
hopefully what we want that if K is
large enough if the number of if this
balance is very very small so every
point has very little mass then
everything sort of becomes independent
and by Chernov and hardening we can get
what we want
ok X is very very balanced and then ok
so on one hand if we increase M then we
can get our guarantees on the other hand
if X behaves very nicely we get also our
guarantees the problem is this is not
really true so it's good as intuition
but it's it doesn't really work so the
Chernoff and hafting bound do not work
you you're welcome to try this at home
and but as intuition it serves something
so what is the right side of here so the
question is this so we fix
epsilon and Delta so we have a fixed
budget for M and we know exactly how
large the L can be and how often we
allow ourselves to make arrows so we
define the new of M epsilon and Delta to
be the maximum new such that if this
quotient is smaller than you then
feature hashing works okay a new
basically was open since the original
paper about Weinberger and arrow okay so
is the problem clear not at least again
exactly one good question that's an
excellent question so the quick answer
is yes yeah so the question was if this
isn't just count sketch with one block
of one building block of count sketch so
the decay answer is yes although the
perspective is a little bit different so
if you think about the feature hashing
matrix okay with M equals one over
epsilon square this is exactly count
sketch okay and the count sketch
algorithm repeats this mechanism not 1
over Delta independent times and gets a
high concentration probability so there
are two issues with this approach I mean
it's not a problem but let's say it's a
different perspective of things so here
the effective sparsity eventually is log
1 of the Delta over epsilon squared over
Epsilon
ok so you don't get a better bounce for
the time it takes to apply the embedding
another thing is so when you have when
you compute the norm of the sketch you
take all these sketches you compute each
of the norms individually and you
compute the median and
returned the median that's how can
sketch works for to get the high
probability balance and this is not an
embedding to a metric space in our in
many application we need the sketch to
be an actual embedding to actually a
linear embedding into the target space
but as I said it's it's I mean this is
much sparser so Kane and Nelson the
matrix constructed by Kane and Nelson
has loved one of a delta over epsilon
ones in each column this has 1 1 in each
column and and surprisingly enough it
works very well in practice so but again
to get so count sketch is usually in the
literature analyzed using first and
second moments so the second moment
method that I showed earlier is exactly
how how we analyze count sketch so but
apparently count sketch can do much
better if you analyze it more carefully
yeah ok so our result so the problem is
clear there's just to be I was on my way
to ask you to at least nod to see that
everything is clear sure so that's for
ask you better I guess
for the vectors which don't wish what
was the newest large I don't know no so
that they're the actually the low bond
is on a balance vector if I'm not
mistaken
yeah but I'm allowing the dimension of
the range to increase so the lower bound
was if you insisted that I mention is
optimal lock one over delta of epsilon
square but I'm allowing the dimension to
be larger okay so in fact I'm fixing em
but I am NOT insisting that M is the
optimal suppose I have a larger budget
and I want to use it okay
any more questions okay so what we
proved is the following if M is very
small basically smaller than the
joseline dasta's dimension then we can't
do anything ok we can talk no matter how
small nu is if n is larger as I showed
you before if M is much much larger than
we can do everything we can sketch every
vector and in between these two yeah
this is the right bound
so yeah the chain said I think that
epsilon to the 2/3 what was weird so
yeah this is the right bound and this is
tight so this is the right bound yeah
it's not our fault this is the right
bound so how do we prove it so first of
all we take this variable X which is the
difference between the original norm and
the new norm and we prove tight bounds
on higher order moments of X ok and then
we use known concentration bounds which
are I mean the concentration bounds that
we use are simple the application is not
so simple this is Markov this is
perishable these are basically first and
second order concentration bounds this
is the hard part of the proof this is
just they're not so easy part of the
proof
so yeah I'm gonna take a few minutes to
just show you how to expand this it's
gonna be a little bit painful but bear
with me so we call that f of X the I
coordinate is this expression and let's
focus for simplicity it's going to be
hard enough as it is
let's focus for simplicity on this
balanced vector there this is actually
the vector on which the lower bound is
attained so this is the hardest vector
to map ok so if we concentrate on this
vector then this is f of X the eye
coordinate if we square it then we get
just firstly we get this so we
substitute this and we get this nice
thing now we sum of all pairs J and L
that ledge HJ and L are mapped to the
same bucket
note that if J is equal L this is always
true ok and this happens K times times 1
over K we lose the 1 here and we stay
with this expression now we raise it to
the ALF power and trust me you get this
thing ok and then we just take the
expectation and use linearity so we sum
over all our sequences of pairs of
distinct pairs I mean JP is not equal is
not equal LP for all P let's focus on
one such servant
so we take a sequence and we can think
of this sequence isn't a labeled card
okay we can think of every pair as an
edge and these are ordered but and this
can be actually a multi graph and the
same age can occur several times in the
sequence so one thing you should note
first is that this is available and
these are independent so we can split
the expectation now we just write this
differently so for every J Sigma J
appears how many times if you think
about it as a function of the graph
there it's exactly the degree of the
node J in the graph okay so this is this
and all these Sigma J's are independent
so I can move the expectation back in
now what happens if the degree is odd
the expectation is zero right if the
degree is even it's identically wanted
this is a degenerate variable so all
nodes must have even degree n over in
order for the cement to be nonzero and
then we just remained with this
expression now how do we analyze this so
think of a graph like this first thing
you should note is that every connected
component the respective variables are
yeah I don't know what the white is
middle circle is not that but they are
independent
okay now consider one such connected
component
what will it contribute so the expected
value of this edge no many how no matter
how many times I put it in and this edge
the the product is one over m squared
because I need all three to be mapped to
the same bucket and in fact what matters
is the number of nodes in each connected
component and not the edges the edges I
don't care about so every connected
component contributes 1 over m to the 1
to the 1 less than the size of the
connected component and this gives us
this expression it's better to think
about it like this so every what about
single node it contributes one here and
one here
we can ignore this and we get that the
expected value of the product over there
is one over m to the power of number of
non isolated where this is my minus
number of non degenerate connected
components this means not I don't count
single versus isolated vertices here
okay
is that clear so going back to the
Highland or the moment we sum over all
possible alpha and beta 1 over m to the
alpha minus beta where G alpha beta is
the number of graphs that actually
basically satisfy what we discussed here
so they have our labeled edges they are
Eulerian meaning that every connected
component is Eulerian they have alpha
non isolated vertices and beta and non
degenerate connected components okay so
the I mean the hard part is to count how
many such graphs other ok so I think da
cunha was mentioned before today so the
theorem we have we have tight bounds up
to to to the are factors of the number
of such graphs so if you fix our alpha
and beta G of alpha beta is up to 2 to
the R factor this expression okay are we
good are we on the same page I mean
ignore the formula just under are you
following why we need this so how is the
number of edges are like that I realized
I mean the piece was 6 to the R so this
is the number of edges here okay so
ignore the formula are you clear on why
we need to count this these graphs okay
yeah formulas are not nice here but as I
said this is tight they are also doing
the counting of these types of
yes so what happens is the que Nelson
approach since they had loved one over
Delta over epsilon once I keep getting
back to that but then you have you can
prove concentration by using certain
tools and these tools don't work here
since we only have unique one so for
example they use the concentration on a
binomial distributed random variables so
if you have a binomial and you only have
one experiment it's just a Bernoulli
experiment you can't really prove from
concentration so so the machinery could
not be extended to to prove bounds for
free charging okay so to prove the upper
bound we show that every graph in this
family I'm abusing notation a little bit
was this number before and now it's set
I know but we don't need any more
notations here right so we show that it
can be encoded using few bits do I have
five more minutes yeah okay so let's
just quickly see the idea so fix some
goth and let these be the nondegenerate
connected components in this graph take
one connected component for each
connected component we choose
arbitrarily three in that connected
component okay and we encode these alpha
minus beta edges okay remember we have
beta connected components each component
has a tree the sum of number of edges is
alpha minus beta each each component
contributes one less than the number of
nodes and this can be done using alpha
minus beta times 2 times 2 log alpha
bits we simply so we call it alpha node
so each node can have a log log alpha
sides by a label and we simply encode
the edges okay now that's a subtle point
we choose an extra edge in each
connected component and we know that
there is such an edge why is that
what it's your Aryan exactly so we know
that the sub love is Eulerian and then
we know there must be at least one more
edge and this edge can be as infect and
coded very succinctly so if we order the
connected components by the smallest
node then we know the ordering by now if
you think about decoding later once we
have the trees we know the ordering so
we can refer to each connected component
by a place in this ordering plus a label
within its own edges okay and this sums
up to be this many bits and the rest of
the edges we just encode them as
elements in this set okay and now you
have to trust me that this is what you
get yeah I won't get into that for the
lower bound I won't get into this it Hey
also because I'm almost out of time I
think but we basically construct a large
subfamily of G alpha beta which is large
enough to be this size up to 2 to the
minus now and I think I'll stop here
[Applause]
yes could you repeat the slide with the
statement of the result of whether what
the statement of the result yeah
someone
ah yeah let's leave it at that
sorry
yes
yeah
well that's a question of why what I
will able to question but I'll ask it
offline okay
so just yeah when M is at the minimum
value yeah you mean here right but if
it's like twice that value right okay
yeah so we go back to if M is its order
of wood Epsilon yeah wait no it's not so
this is uh this is a constant and I
think it's good
epsilon log 1 over epsilon square of log
1 over epsilon over log 1 over Delta or
something like that
yeah just substitute it here I'm not
sure actually I think it's this it
depends on how epsilon and Delta relate
to each other so this is log 1 over
epsilon over log 1 over Delta and this
is just constant over log 1 over Delta
so it depends on epsilon and Delta if I
have a binary feature vector that this
is saying you need something like more
than one over epsilon features ok so you
need that you need the original vector
to have one of us in yes oh yeah so
again it depends on epsilon and Delta
but yes ok this is this is more involved
than it seems
yeah I don't think I got it so covered
so
yep
okay so basically we know that in you if
nu is small enough then it works and if
nu is very large it doesn't work but the
right bound was was not known
yes so the other bounders who's fully
random a she I guess so yeah so the
theoretical bounds are for completely
random hashing in practice it works very
well with much less randomness for
example mix tabulation hashing so we
have experiments I did not include them
here but but it works very well with and
in fact if I already mention the
experiments so they show that actually
the constant here is very close to 1 so
the constant hiding in the theta
notation it's very close with just
simple mix tabulation hashing so you
don't need the entire power fully
randomized hash function but proving it
is still a loser
so obviously love 1 over Delta
randomness is enough but I mean this all
works with log 1 over Delta
and what questions it's think year again
[Applause]